[Music]
the story I wanted to share with you
today it's my challenge as an Iranian
artist as an Iranian woman artist as an
Iranian woman artist living in exile
well it has this plusses and minuses and
the dark side politic doesn't seem to
escape people like me every Iranian
artist in one form and another is
political politic has defined our lives
if you're living in Iran you're facing
censorship harassment arrest torture at
times execution if you're living outside
like me you're faced with a life in
exile the pain of the longing and the
separation from your loved one and your
family therefore we don't find the moral
emotional psychological and political
space to distance ourselves from the
reality of social responsibility
oddly enough and artists such as myself
finds herself also in the position of
being the voice the Speaker of my people
even if I have indeed no access to my
own country also people like myself
we're fighting two battles in different
grounds we're being critical of the West
the perception of the West about our
identity about the image that is
constructed about us about our woman
about our politics about our religion we
are there to take pride and insist on
respect at the same time we're fighting
another battle that is our regime our
governments our atrocious government who
has done every crime in order to stay in
power our artists are at risk
we are in a position of danger we pose a
threat to the order of the government
but ironically this situation has
empowered all of us because we are
considered as artists central to the
cultural political social discourse in
Iran we are there to inspire to provoke
to mobilize to bring hope to our people
we are the reporters of our people and
our communicators to the outside world
art is our weapon culture is a form of
resistance I am me sometimes the artists
of the West for their freedom of
expression for the fact that they can
distance themselves from the question of
politics from the fact that the only
serving one audience mainly the Western
culture but also I worry about the West
because often in this country in this
Western world that we have culture risk
to be a form of entertainment
our people depend on our artists and
culture is beyond communication my
journey as an artist started from a very
very personal place I did not start to
make social commentary about my country
the first one that you see in front of
you is actually when I first returned to
Iran after being separated for good 12
years it was after the Islamic
Revolution of 1979 while I was in
absence from Iran the Islamic Revolution
had descended on Iran it entirely
transformed the country from Persian to
the Islamic culture I came mainly to be
reunited with my family and to reconnect
in a way that I found my place in the
society but instead I found the country
that was totally ideological and that I
didn't recognize anymore more so I
I'm very interested as I was facing my
own personal dilemmas and questions
I became immersed in the study of the
Islamic Revolution how indeed it had
incredibly transformed the lives of
Iranian women I found the subject of
Iranian women immensely interesting in
the way that the women of Iran
historically seemed to embody the
political transformations so in a way by
studying a woman you can read the
structure and the ideology of the
country so I made a group of work that
at once faced my own personal questions
in life and yet it brought my work into
a larger discourse the subject of
martyrdom the question of those who
willingly stand in that intersection of
love of God faith but violence and crime
and cruelty for me this became
incredibly important and yet I had a
neutral position toward this I was an
outsider who had come back to Iran to
find my place but I was not in a
position to be critical of the
government or the ideology of the
Islamic Revolution this changed slowly
as I found my voice and I discovered
things that I didn't know I would
discover so my art became slightly more
critical my knife became a little
sharper and I fell into a life in exile
I am a nomadic artist I work in Morocco
in Turkey in Mexico I go everywhere to
make believe is Iran now I'm making
films last year I finished a film called
woman without men woman without men
returns to history but another part of
our Iranian history it goes to 1953 when
American CIA exercised a coup I removed
a democratically elected leader dr.
Masada the book it's written by an
Iranian woman shaman power supports a
magic realist novel this book is banned
she spent five years in prison my
obsession with this book and the reason
I made this into a film because it at
once was addressing the question of
being a female traditionally
historically in Iran and the question of
for woman who were all looking for an
idea of change freedom and democracy
well the country of Iran equally as if
another character also struggled for an
idea of freedom and democracy and
independence from the foreign
interventions I made this film because I
felt it's important for it to speak to
the Westerners about our history as a
country that all of you seem to remember
Iran after the Islamic Revolution that
Iran was once a secular society and we
had democracy and this democracy was
stolen from us by the American
government by the British government
this film also speaks to the Iranian
people in asking them to return to their
history and look at themselves before
they were so is Lama sized in the way we
looked in the way we played music in the
way we had intellectual life and most of
all in the way that we fought for
democracy these are some of the shots
actually from my film
these are some of the images of the coup
and we made this film in Casablanca
recreating all the shots
this film tried to find a balance
between telling a political story but
also a feminine story being a visual art
is indeed I am for most interested to
make art to make art that transcends
politics religion the question of
feminism and become an important
timeless Universal work of art the
challenge I have is how to do that how
to tell a political story by the
allegorical story how to move you with
your emotions but also make your mind
work these are some of the images and
the characters of the film
now comes the green movement summer of
2009 as my film is released the uprising
begins in the streets of Tehran
what is unbelievably ironic is a period
that we try to depict in the film the
cry for democracy and social social
justice repeats itself now again in
Tehran the green movement significantly
inspired the world it brought a lot of
attention to all those Iranians who
stand for basic human rights and
struggle for democracy what was most
significant for me was once again the
presence of the woman there absolutely
inspirational for me if in the Islamic
Revolution the images of the woman
portrayed were submissive and didn't
have a voice
now we saw a new idea of feminism in the
streets of Tehran woman who were
educated forward-thinking
non-traditional sexually open fearless
and seriously feminist this woman and
those young men United Iranians across
the world inside and outside I then
discovered why I take so much
inspiration from Iranian women that
under all circumstances they have pushed
the boundary they have confronted your
authority they have broken every rule in
the smallest and the biggest way and
once again they prove themselves I stand
here to say that Iranian women have
found a new voice and their voice is
giving me my voice and it's a great
honor to be an Iranian woman and in your
honor an artist even if I have to
operate in the West only for now thank
you so much
[Applause]
you